I've learned a lot of my lessons in life
from movies there's a movie called
Sullivan's travels that like taught me
more than I ever thought I could and
it's like the Merit in making people
laugh might be one of the greatest gifts
you could ever give which you have done
so
generously we tried you know you
succeeded on not in this film but
definitely in the in in the television
show that I don't even know if I can say
but shit's creek Absol I always I know I
got in
trouble I how did
I I know I know I know you get to like
be in and collaborate with your dad I
know and what is bizarre I mean it was
great it was great I mean Eugene Levy is
he's a comedy God you you did something
so important for the world it's just the
coincidence of timing it was like the
right story at the right time so we're
very grateful for it but it was your
mother that broke my heart the most she
wrote a
tweet it was took place on the finale
today I regret every single second of
worry back in the uninformed 80s
wondering how the world was going to
treat my brilliant little boy who loved
to twirl little did I know that he was
going to kick that world's bleep to the
curb and create a brand new one
I
know it took us all by surprise
listen moms moms moms you know yeah
she's a great writer she is great writer
and I just think that if all of us
parents in the world can read something
like that we might know to stop worrying
so much and believe that one day we also
too could be proud knowing our kids are
okay and that was what I took from it
because we're all in this mode of I just
want you to be okay I want you to be
okay and I just thought it was the most
beautiful thing I'd ever read as a so
her being a writer